The launch of a new coal mine
in Australia has divided the country.
No more coal!
We have to take strong directions,
civil disobedience.
They are over here
pleading with our governments
not to build new coal mines.
We have a responsibility to them.
An energy giant seeks
to generate electricity in India
and create jobs across Australia.
The opportunity is to feed
the very best coal to those plants.
We have an industry
to be super proud of.
Adani is a revolution
for us in central Queensland,
because it's going to give us
job opportunities.
But some fear the impact
on Australia's natural resources.
Our own government is destroying
the Great Barrier Reef.
We've lost about half of all the corals
of the Great Barrier Reef.
With communities bracing for impact
in their neighbourhoods.
Yes, that's a water bomber.
He's gone back to the airport to refill
because there's a fire
still going back there.
In 30 years,
when we've got raging bush fires,
our waters running out,
we can't grow crops anymore.
Can the Australian government
fight the realities of climate change?
We're getting more cyclones,
we're getting monsoonal events,
and climate change is a big issue.
Queensland, Australia.
Suburbs in the south-eastern tip
of the country
are engulfed in bushfires.
Catastrophic, hot, drought-like conditions
with wind speeds of 90 miles an hour.
The fires spread fast.
People are evacuated to safety,
while more than 20 homes
are burnt to ashes.
Rescue services use aerial bombers
to douse the fires,
now spread over 4,200 acres.
An emergency is declared
in vast swathes of Queensland.
In May 2019,
65% of Queensland
was declared to be in drought.
Water supplies for farms and
homes are running dry.
We travel to Stanthorpe,
a suburban town
two hours from Brisbane,
to investigate the impact
of this heatwave.
That's James Morris from
the New South Wales Rural Fire Service
giving us the latest update on the...
The severity of dwindling water supplies
can be gauged
by the signboards that welcome us.
As we arrive, firefighters leave
to douse raging fires nearby.
Stanthorpe's community meeting is called.
Local police and the mayor
have urgent announcements.
I can't stress enough that there are
exclusion zones for safety reasons.
We've got trees that have been burnt out
in those dry roots systems
that could easily fall over on cars.
There are power lines down.
You could see the direction of winds
that was going,
and it did with speed
and ferocious flames.
The residents are holed up
inside the centre,
unsure if their homes
have survived the blaze.
While outside,
water bombing continues.
As fires briefly subside,
70-year-old Kerry Stratford
is allowed back into her home.
This was all alight on Friday night
when I watched all this burn.
And that house up there
is called the Eagle's Nest.
And I'm surprised that the Eagle's Nest
escaped because it was just burning.
They had to call
the fire inspector yesterday
to put the fire out.
But it got up to there, it stopped there.
So, there must have been
a heap of fire here.
See that brown thing
behind those rocks?
That's melted. There's a little car.
That's a water tank.
It's melted.
The top of it is melted.
That's how hot the fire was.
Kerry's home miraculously survived.
The fire stopped a few metres
from where she lives.
When you're faced with
not having a home to come back to...
And that's the thing.
That's still getting to me,
how lucky I am that my home survived.
I've got my late husband's voice
on the phone,
that's the only thing
I've got of hearing him talk.
And that was when it snowed here,
on 17 August, 2015.
That's when it snowed.
They evacuated those people out of there.
The hardest thing is when
you get the knock on the door.
You know it's coming
from the police saying, "Get out".
And I said, "Oh yeah, I've got
everything packed, everything ready."
And he said,
"Well, make sure you go."
Stanthorpe's remaining water supply
is being sacrificed for firefighting.
Well, the fact that we've been
in drought up here for so long,
we haven't had decent rain for...
a good two years now,
We've had sporadic rain.
If you go have a look
at Storm King Dam.
That'll shock you,
because that's really shocking out there.
We're on severe water restrictions.
We'll be out of water
at the town here by December.
And I don't know if they're using
the water from our dam out there
to fill fire bombers for this.
Don't know where they are
getting their water from.
The fires have shattered livelihoods,
animal habitats,
water supplies, and agriculture.
According to
the Climate Council of Australia,
economic loss due to
reduced agricultural productivity
is projected to exceed
$19 billion by 2030,
$211 billion by 2050,
and $4 trillion by 2100.
Re-using water has now become
the only way to survive the drought
in many parts of the country.
My bath water is still in there,
because I saved that.
And then I used my bucket
that I got there in the washing machine.
I'll have to get that a rinse there.
There's all ashes in there
from the fire,
from the ashes that come through.
So, a bucket up with that bucket in there,
wash my clothes in it,
hang it out.
Then put it out into the bucket,
and then it goes on what plants
I've got to keep alive.
That's the only way
you water the plants.
There's no doubt the climate is evolving,
it is changing.
But I know that we're getting
a few degrees warmer each year.
We've noticed a big increase
in the global warming,
But I don't know how you stop that.
There's something definitely
happening with the Earth.
The State of the Climate 2018
report for Australia
reveals a land surface temperature
increase of 1 degree Celsius.
That's led to hot, dry conditions,
perfect for bushfires.
The science was saying then
that if we keep putting carbon dioxide
and methane into the atmosphere,
the temperature will steadily increase.
There will be more frequent extremes,
more very hot days.
There'll be changes to rainfall patterns.
The science was saying 30 years ago
that Perth, Adelaide, Melbourne,
the southern cities of Australia
would get dryer,
and that's all happened.
Already, Australia is ranked
the 7th highest carbon emitter per capita.
One big reason, coal-fired power plants.
Coal provides fuel for about 70%
of electricity production in Australia.
A majority of these plants are located
in the state of Queensland.
The state has
a historical relationship with coal.
Mining began here in the 18th century.
Behind most coal mining operations
lay years of struggle and toil.
This coal earned royalties
for the Queensland government
and sparked development
across the country.
But today, the region
is a shadow of its past,
with coal jobs lost to automation.
Still, coal production continues to grow
to feed a hungry market abroad.
Now, instead of reducing
Australia's carbon footprint,
the Queensland premier has promised
to open new coal mines in her state.
It's part of Annastacia Palaszczuk's plan
to create thousands of new jobs.
But at what price?
Australia is the world's
largest exporter of coal,
a commodity that's aided
the rise in temperatures worldwide.
Coal-fired electricity generation
accounted for 30%
of global CO2 emissions,
according to
the International Energy Agency,
resulting in record temperatures
of 40 degrees Celsius in Australia,
leaving the residents of Stanthorpe
desperate for water.
As rescue services
scramble to save lives,
Queensland's premier calls
for an emergency press conference.
So, we have a number
of families at the moment
that are actually going through
some really traumatic times.
So, we are in the process
of trying to reach those families.
We understand that they're all safe,
but they will be going through
a lot of grief at the moment,
and I know that our community
will pull together
and definitely make sure
that they get back on their feet.
Premier, we're filming a documentary
from Singapore, from Channel NewsAsia.
Just wanted to get a comment from you
about the increasing number of coal mines
resulting in rising temperatures.
Do you feel that this
is a direct impact of that?
Well, we do know that
climate change has a big impact.
We knew that
we are getting more cyclones,
we're getting monsoonal events,
and climate change is a big issue
that everyone signs up to
in terms of keeping with the Paris treaty.
But the latest addition
to Queensland's coal industry
has incensed thousands of anti-coal
protesters across the country.
No more coal!
After the break,
we investigate the politics
of coal in Australia.
Two-thirds of extreme weather events
in the last 20 years
were caused by human activities.
The Paris Agreement signed in 2016
aimed to curb emissions to minimise
temperature rise by 1.5 degrees.
If current trends continue,
the world is likely to pass
the 1.5-degree Celsius mark
between 2030 and 2052,
unless it finds a way
to reach net zero emissions.
Amid this alarming situation,
the state of Queensland
announced new coal mines
to boost the economy and create jobs.
That's when Indian billionaire
Gautam Adani
announced plans to build
a mine at Carmichael,
a rural outpost
in the Australian outback.
At the time, Carmichael was to excavate
60 million tonnes of coal a year.
That figure has since been scaled down.
In effect, what we are building now
is a 10 million tonne per annum coal mine.
We are just one of 125
operating coal mines in Australia.
We'll be building 200 kilometres
of greenfield rail construction
tied to the existing rail network.
So combined,
that will be AU$2 billion investment
to be able to get us into production,
and we'll see that coming online in 2021.
The mine would be located
on the Galilee Basin,
160 kilometres north-west of Clermont.
It would also feature a rail line
connecting the mine
to the Abbot Point terminal.
The opening of the Carmichael mine
is expected to attract
more investments in the mining sector,
which activists say would
increase greenhouse emissions
that trap heat and
make the planet warmer.
Roughly 30% of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions
came from electricity production
from coal and gas in 2018.
Australia's mining sector,
once the backbone of the economy,
is in a long-protracted slump.
I think a lot more businesses
are going to close,
which a lot have already closed.
Haven't they, right?
They've had to close the doors
because there's no people in the town.
People have to move away
because there is nothing here, you know?
The younger generation's got no future.
Yeah, that's right.
The younger generation of Bowen,
they've got nothing.
What did they turn to?
Look around, the town is dead,
completely, completely dead.
And the town
needs employment real bad.
There's nothing here
for the younger generation.
They all leave town.
Adani announced thousands of jobs
to be created over the next few years,
a prospect much welcomed
by the mining community.
The pro-Adani movement was
centred around jobs,
jobs for the community.
Claremont is a very strong mining town.
I think it was founded on copper mining
back in the 1800s.
And obviously then gold,
and the people of Claremont
following the investment,
and in town,
and the ability for those people
that gained jobs
was very pro-Adani, I think.
I believe that mining is important.
I don't think that
it's sustainable to think
that we can go straight
from coal-fired power
to natural resources like wind or solar,
but I think they should work
hand in hand.
A number of people locally
work in the mining industry,
so a lot of them are quite keen,
I believe, to get more jobs in that area.
Unemployment here hovers above 9%,
compared to around 6%
in Queensland as a whole.
That's why Bruce Hedditch
is busy promoting the Adani mine.
He started the Go Adani campaign.
It's going to generate a lot of
job opportunities for central Queensland.
The Queensland government last year
received $3.8 billion in coal royalties
from coal mines throughout this state.
$3.8 billion.
Next year, the Queensland government
will spend $3.9 billion
on interest on loans.
Now, the opponents of Adani and coal
are asking us, as a community,
to stop coal exports,
stop the world from coming through.
I would love someone to tell me
where the $3.8 billion
is going to come from.
For a town devoid of jobs,
it's a polarising question of
unemployment versus the environment.
There are questions about whether or not
the mine will pay appropriate royalties
or any royalties to our state government,
and huge concerns about the fact that
there won't be that many jobs provided,
and that the company has effectively...
massively exaggerated the jobs
that they say it would provide.
Adani's initial promise
of thousands of new jobs
was challenged by a court testimony.
An affidavit alleged that Adani Mining's
billion-dollar Carmichael Coal Project
would have 483 full-time
equivalent jobs,
while Queensland as a whole would have
1,206 full-time equivalent jobs.
We'll see over 1,500
direct jobs being created
during the ramp up and construction
for the mine and rail,
and a further 6,750 indirect jobs.
In total, what we're talking is 8,250 jobs
injected into the Australian economy,
and in particular,
regional Queensland,
and specifically in areas that have
typically high levels of unemployment.
We're talking about areas
that have approached
close to 10% levels of unemployment.
So, the project
is certainly very important
for Australia and for Queensland,
regional Queensland as it relates to jobs.
Jobs aside, TV journalist Mark Willacy
has news that's far less hopeful.
He tracked developments
on Adani Mining elsewhere.
The company was charged in Zambia
with polluting a major river
and convicted.
Under Australian law,
if you have any convictions
or issues involving mining,
and you're in charge,
you have to declare that.
That was not declared by this
particular Adani executive at the time.
And that coal mine had recently
with Adani being charged,
and it's going to be prosecuted for
supplying false and misleading information
to the state government
here in Queensland.
The State of Queensland imposed
hundreds of environmental conditions
for the Carmichael mine to adhere to.
Particular attention was paid
to Adani's surface water use
and the mine's proximity
to the Great Artesian Basin.
The Great Artesian Basin is the biggest
underwater resource in the world,
stretching over 1.7 million
square kilometres.
It is 3,000 metres deep in places,
and is estimated to contain
65,000 cubic kilometres of groundwater.
The basin provides
the only source of fresh water
to much of inland Australia.
Underground coal mines rely on water
to reduce the risk of fires or explosions
by using it to cool the cutting surfaces
of mining equipment,
and prevent coal dust
from catching fire.
So, we know about water
being very precious.
The Adani mine would suck up as much water
as the rest of the users
in the whole catchment,
and they don't have to pay as much for it
because our state laws are very lax
and give a whole lot of freebies
to mining companies
for reasons that we can go into later.
Mostly because they make
generous donations
to both sides of politics.
We will not be extracting water
from the Great Artesian Basin.
We don't have any plans,
we don't have any authority,
we don't have any approvals
to extract water
from the Great Artesian Basin.
There are instances where we will
have to extract groundwater
simply to allow our mining
to be undertaken safely,
so it's simply for safety reasons,
not for water extraction reasons.
And outside of that, all of our water
will be sourced from surface sources.
Tom Cothers,
a former Queensland water chief,
estimates the mine may tap
on a substantial amount
of the state's water resources.
When Adani starts to extract coal
and intercepts
the Great Artesian Basin aquifers,
water will flow out of those aquifers
into the mine pits,
and Adani are allowed to extract
unlimited volumes of water
out of those mine pits
to keep their mining operations safe.
Adani has modelled an extraction
of water over the life of the mine,
it's 270 gigalitres.
That is equivalent to around
about 55% of Sydney harbour.
Animal graziers like Bruce Currie
rely on the Great Artesian Basin
for their water supplies.
He lives in Speculation,
a rural outpost in the Australian outback.
People can't exist without water.
If you want to know
what I'm talking about,
turn your water supply off for two days
and try and survive,
regardless of where you are.
Because what's happening here,
they're turning our water off
for perpetuity.
When they destroy it, it's gone forever.
Along with wife Annette,
the Curries have been running
this farmland for generations.
This is the coal seam that they wanted
to get, the 'D' coal seams.
This is where we draw our water from,
which is the Clematis Sandstone.
And that is part of the feed
into the Great Artesian Basin.
The only thing is once
they mine that coal seam out,
they have a process
called longwall mining.
And what it does is
once the coal comes out,
they just collapse
all the strata above it.
So, what that'll do,
it will drain that Clematis Sandstone.
So basically,
it will destroy our water supply,
and it will destroy part of the feed
into the Great Artesian Basin,
and which will impact on the integrity
of the Great Artesian Basin.
Bruce's worries about
destroyed water supplies
inspired him to go on
a fact-finding walkabout overseas.
He wanted to see what the future
of Speculation might look like,
way out in India.
I went to India a few years ago
to actually have a look
at the Adani operation,
and to talk to...
My main concern was
to talk to communities
and farmers over in that area,
and get a good understanding
of the company that would be coming.
While I was in India, we went to...
the Adani special economic zone
up there in the Gulf of Kutch.
And I spoke to fishermen there,
and they highlighted to me the pressures
and the impacts that they are suffering,
because the Tatas, as well as Adani,
have built a power station there.
They actually released their hot water
out into the ocean,
and which kills the juvenile fish,
fish eggs,
and has a big impact
on the fishing communities
that are trying to survive
on that source of income.
They're also not doing anything about
the fly ash that's coming out of their...
the stacks of their power stations.
And that fly ash is going
across farmer's lands.
Bruce is unsure if similar damage
to the Great Artesian Basin is reversible.
Once the mine starts
and the de-watering starts,
whether their findings
are accurate or not,
they cannot repair the damage,
and the water is mined forever.
It's lost for perpetuity.
Regardless how big their mistake is,
they cannot rectify it.
They cannot correct it.
And the impact is there for perpetuity.
As the climate gets hotter and drier,
water is even more precious.
Farmers like Bruce want their groundwater
to be protected from any damage.
It's a shame that
more people aren't aware
of what the Great Artesian Basin
is all about.
It's one of the biggest underground
fresh water sources in the world.
And it's not polluted,
it's not contaminated.
It's environmental terrorism.
The money we've made and the life
we've lived on Speculation...
And to think that they could just...
through the flick of a pen,
take that away from us.
It's not fair and it's not right.
Like when you went to India to have
a look at those poor farmers over there,
I don't begin to understand
how that has affected their family.
What would we do?
After a prolonged legal battle,
the Adani Carmichael mine has received
the environmental clearances it needs.
But the opposition
to its construction continues.
After the break,
we go underwater to investigate
the impact of rising greenhouse gases
on the Great Barrier Reef.
There are parts of the Great Barrier Reef
where you can drive on a boat
or swim for kilometres
without seeing a living coral.
Indian energy giant Adani
wants to mine Australian coal,
planning to export it back to India.
Adani is the largest private
thermal power producer in India,
with an installed capacity
of more than 12,000 megawatts.
But they're ramping up
production in India.
Adani stands to gain from the rising need
for power in developing South Asia.
To fill the gap in supply,
it's looking at Australian coal.
The coal will be shipped through
the Abbot Point port operations.
It's been operating for over 35 years
in an environmentally responsible way.
There's thousands of ship movements
through the Great Barrier Reef every year.
So, the prospect that the shipment
of our coal through the Great Barrier Reef
is going to have a direct impact
on the reef is just a falsehood.
To export this coal,
Adani signed a 99-year lease
with Abbot Point Terminal in 2011.
The deal cost Adani roughly AU$2 billion.
A few years back, there was a plan
for massive expansion of ports
in the Great Barrier Reef
and there's basically 6 big ports already.
And there was a hope by the industry,
with their hand being held by government,
to expand those ports
to ship more coal out,
and more liquefied natural gas out
through the Great Barrier Reef
to world export markets.
Now, the problem with making ports
bigger and deeper
is that it requires
a huge amount of dredging.
So, the huge impacts from that dredging
were a very big concern
to marine scientists.
The developments surrounding
Abbot Point port
are being keenly watched
by coral expert Charlie Veron.
That's because of Abbot Point's
close proximity
to the Great Barrier Reef Marine Park.
The Great Barrier Reef
is the world's largest coral reef system,
composed of over 2,900 individual reefs,
large enough that it can be seen
from outer space.
This is the world's
biggest single structure
made by living organisms.
Reefs occupy just 1%
of the world's marine environment,
but they provide a home
to a quarter of all marine species,
including unique fish, turtles and algae.
A large part of the reef is protected
by the Great Barrier Reef Marine Park,
which helps to limit
the impact of human use,
such as fishing and tourism.
The reef has lost more than half
its coral cover since 1985.
High temperatures
cause mass coral bleaching
due to warm ocean waters.
A coral reef
is a very competitive environment.
Everything competes
with everything else all the time.
So, corals have got
the symbiosis with the algae,
and that produces food and oxygen.
But if you raise the temperature
just above the absolute
temperature tolerance the corals have,
the algae produce too much oxygen,
and that kills them.
We head out to investigate
the effects of rising temperatures
on the Great Barrier Reef.
Charlie Veron is out to collect evidence.
He's hoping the remaining reef
might be spared from rising temperatures.
There are parts of the Great Barrier Reef
where you can drive in a boat
or swim for kilometres
without seeing a living coral.
So, the worst affected
is total death of the whole reef.
And we see that in a few reefs,
but the majority of reefs
are the Great Barrier,
have not been wiped out by any means,
but they have been quite
severely damaged.
Reefs protect coastlines from flooding
during extreme storms,
which is why saving corals is critical.
As the seas warm,
and they're warming gradually every year,
the increase that threatens corals
warms incrementally.
Just each year,
it gets more and more threatening.
And whether that kills the corals or not
depends on the amount of time
it's exposed to these maximum conditions,
maximum temperature conditions.
That varies in patches
all over the ocean surface,
but it is increasing year by year,
and that will continue.
Charlie is now retired,
but has spent his life
raising awareness of coral bleaching.
The other is direct lying,
direct telling of lies by politicians.
For example,
politicians say that Australia...
is meeting all its obligations
under the Kyoto and the Paris Agreement.
Australia is going absolutely nowhere
near meeting its obligations.
Now, it is not possible for a politician
to not know the truth,
because scientists know the truth.
Scientists tell the politicians.
It's all in publications
of all different levels.
So, if you want to say
we are meeting our obligations
under all these treaties
that have happened,
you are not telling the truth.
And again, that's political.
A report card by the government's
Australian Institute of Marine Science
wasn't encouraging.
Rising water temperatures
are likely to cause more coral bleaching,
producing irreversible damage to the reef.
Scientists expect the coral may recover
over the next five to ten years,
but only if another mass bleaching event
doesn't occur during that time.
That's unlikely,
given the current trajectory
of climate change.
In 2015,
Australia Institute put
the Carmichael mine's expected emissions
over the next 30 years into perspective.
It believes the annual carbon emissions
of this single coal mine
would be three times the average
annual emissions from New Delhi,
double those from Tokyo,
six times that of Amsterdam,
and 20% more than New York City,
if the mine produces
40 mega tonnes per year.
Adding more carbon dioxide from mines
can potentially threaten thousands
of animal species that rely on the reef.
Not to mention the $6.4 billion
in tourism revenue
and 64,000 full-time jobs
the Great Barrier Reef
provides to Australia.
Tourism operator Lindsay Simson
is concerned about her livelihood.
Her boat tours serve
international tourists on a daily basis.
If we add more mines to that,
we're looking at a reef
that's already under terrible threat.
We're looking at 70,000 people
earning their money from tourism,
who won't have anywhere
to take anyone to look at.
And I mean I've had
laughingly heard people say
there's something called
disaster tourism.
She decided to investigate Adani
by traveling to India on her own,
and ended up writing a book.
He was going to bring jobs to everyone.
So, he was going to make it
all good again and give lots of work.
Now, we all know 2%
of Australia's workforce work in mines.
And if you think about that,
it's an automated industry.
If we look at how many
of these people are going to get jobs...
Adani promised in India, he was going
to give all these jobs to locals.
He then imported workers from Orissa
and all these other places.
He did not give the local jobs.
He did for the first year,
and there is evidence
he's giving work now.
That work is not going to be there,
and if you look at it
in terms of long-term work,
1,300 workers is what
he was talking about,
versus 70,000 in tourism,
and those workers
are only going to be "fly-in fly-out".
The coal mine has also sparked
the Native Title Movement.
Every mining project in this country,
it tends to be out in remote country,
and a lot of that country
is traditional aboriginal country.
And under Australian law,
aboriginal people from those areas
can claim what they call native title.
And that's a form of guardianship
over these lands.
Now, no one has taken
guardianship over that land,
but there is an aboriginal group there
that wants to do that,
and they can legitimately
apply to the courts to do that.
As a leader of the Wangan and Jagalingou
native people who owned this land,
Adrian Burragubba took Adani to court.
According to him,
the Carmichael coal mine
can harm around 30,000 hectares
of his community's traditional lands.
Eventually, the court ruled
in favour of Adani Australia,
who are now seeking
$600,000 in court costs,
which would bankrupt Burragubba.
Adrian and his clan have now been barred
from entering their own lands.
This always was aboriginal land.
It always was first
nation's sovereign land
because of our culture
and how we maintain our culture.
And we are not going anywhere.
It's always going to be aboriginal land,
it's always going to be our land.
And if they want to come in here
and try to move us,
and move our sacred site,
then they'll be criticised.
This country will be scrutinised
over the treatment of aboriginal people.
The Wangan and Jagalingou people
will no longer stand
for this bullying tactic from Adani
or from any government in this country.
But Adrian's resistance sparked
a people's movement across Australia,
the Stop Adani movement.
They are over here
pleading with our governments
not to build new coal mines.
We have a responsibility to them,
and to our children, for them
to have a safe future to live in.
The opposition to Adani's Carmichael mine
has sparked a grassroots
environmental movement across Australia.
A loose group of environmental activists,
students and common folk coming together
to pressurise Adani to stop the mine.
Some of them have gathered
at Camp Binbee.
It's called the Stop Adani movement.
We've been given
exclusive access to the camp
after much deliberation
and background checks.
23-year-old Amy Booth
used to live in Victoria,
but decided to join
the Stop Adani movement
in the Australian outback.
People are going to be displaced
by the climate crisis.
I felt that me working in the city,
sort of doing business as usual,
working nine to five, just...
isn't where I want to be right now.
We have a moral obligation to act
and to stop this mine,
and to stop other
environmental problems going ahead.
So, I'm willing to put my life
on hold for the moment
to do what I can
to stop projects like this
from going ahead.
Because this isn't just about
this particular area.
Every project that
is a fossil fuel project
is adding to sea or to the atmosphere,
and that affects the entire globe.
Protesters like Amy believe that if built,
Adani's Carmichael mine
will add billions of tonnes
of carbon pollution to our atmosphere.
In that context,
it is criminally irresponsible
to be proposing the opening
of new coal mines
or new coal-fired power stations.
And the Adani case
is a particularly important one
because that would not just be
a significant coal mine in itself.
It will potentially open up the whole
Galilee Basin as a new coal province.
And there are five or six
other possible coal mines in the pipeline
that would be more likely
to go ahead if Adani started,
because the infrastructure
for getting the coal to port,
for managing water, energy
and infrastructure would be there,
and that would reduce
the start-up costs of other coal mines.
And that's why Adani's become
a really symbolic issue in Australia.
These anti-coal activists are now
taking a more hands-on position
by physically blocking coal trains,
mines and machines,
a strategy now commonly
known as a lockdown.
On 22 July 2019,
protesters set up a blockade
outside the Abbot Point port.
About 20 members
of the environmental group
gathered outside
the port entrance at 7am.
We're ready.
What are we here for, girls?
This footage was filmed by Amy,
as her co-protesters
22-year-old Emily Starr
and 20-year-old Matilda Heselen
locked themselves to a concrete barrel.
We wanted to start acting
to show that we weren't going to let...
We weren't going to sit by
and let this just happen.
So, we locked on in terms of,
we had our arms clipped onto this...
little bar inside a barrel
that was filled with cement
and then there was a PVC tube
that our arms would go down
and be clipped onto.
They stopped the supply of coal for hours.
That's when the Queensland police
stepped in.
As tension mounted,
a French television crew
filmed the action from the side.
I was willing to be arrested, which I was,
because a short-term inconvenience
of being arrested
and being given a fine is okay with me,
because the long-term benefit
of stopping this mine from going ahead
would be amazing.
Amy continued filming events that day.
The journalists and activists are detained
and charged with
trespassing on the railway line.
The French crew were later released
after global condemnation grew.
But they've since been barred
from filming anywhere close to the mine.
They were embarrassed.
They think that that was a mistake,
what the officers did up there.
I know, from the police commissioner down,
that was why the charges were dropped.
So, it was some overzealous policing
by those police officers up there.
Emily and Matilda are now facing
a court hearing at Bowen,
uncertain if they'll be allowed
back into Camp Binbee.
We're hoping that no curve balls
will be thrown when we get in there,
but it'll likely just be sort of...
Well, we're hoping it'll be a fine
with no restitution order against us,
but we're not sure
what it will be, really.
Magistrates can do whatever they like.
After an hour,
they come out of the court.
I felt like he understood
our passion as well,
which I think was really important.
I really liked hearing that
he did understand that.
Even if he didn't necessarily
agree with that.
Yeah, yeah.
I think that in Australia,
we have a huge problem,
and in many places around the world,
where the political systems are broken.
And that's why we've come
to do these kinds of actions,
because we feel like
these are the only sort of things
that can put enough pressure on
political systems to fundamentally change
rather than just sort of
put a band-aid on the issue.
We're at a critical point in history.
There's no doubt that in ecological terms,
we're booked on the Titanic.
We're heading for the iceberg.
And there are still irresponsible people
both literally and metaphorically
throwing coal in the boilers
as if they wanted to get there faster.
Coal particulates pollution
is estimated to shorten some
one million lives annually worldwide.
One study even estimates premature deaths
arising from coal-related air pollution
could be as high
as 52,000 people worldwide.
But with solar and wind power
slowly creeping up,
there's been positive change.
Coal's use has been on the decline
in Europe and the US,
amid cheaper alternatives.
Adani Australia is promoting solar power
as a means to bridge
the gap between coal emissions
and the global push
towards renewable energy.
Rugby Run, which has an initial capacity
of 65 megawatts,
is located near Moranbah.
It's not a question of renewables or coal,
it is renewables and coal.
So, from our perspective,
we've already got around
2,380 megawatts under operation
in relation to solar.
We've got another 2,340 megawatts
currently under construction
of solar capacity.
So, in short,
we've got in excess of 4,700 megawatts
of renewables capacity in our portfolio.
That's a mixture of principally solar,
but we've also got hybrid in there,
including wind.
We see that, moving forward,
in order to meet the developing world's
energy demand and requirements,
it's going to continue to require
underpinning baseload coal-fired
power generation
in addition to renewables
through the likes of solar, wind,
hydro and so forth.
Many believe the solution
to Australia's coal dependence
has to come
from within the political sphere.
The Australian Greens
run on four core values:
ecological sustainability,
social justice,
grassroots democracy,
and peace and non-violence.
We were just sitting in Parliament,
and the best thing
about that whole experience
was that we could hear you
more than we could hear them.
Which is frankly
what a Parliament should be about.
It should be about
the people's voice being heard.
The Greens have a plan to phase out coal,
and create a jobs boom
in the renewable energy export industry.
We have great economic potential
in clean energy.
Here in Queensland,
in Australia, globally,
we know that
there's more jobs in renewables.
We know that renewable energy
can do the job.
We've now got the battery storage,
the solar thermal,
the ways of making clean energy
at 24/7 and dispatchable.
There is no reason
to not go down that path
and actually safeguard humanity.
Australia's current bushfire season
has taken 12 lives,
destroyed millions of hectares of land,
and wiped out nearly 500 million animals,
with no signs of rains
or temperatures subsiding.
Stopping global warming
will require coordinated policies
by national, state,
and local governments,
and the development
of climate-friendly energy policies
that are backed
by politicians and activists alike,
before time runs out,
and the irreversible effects
of climate change
impact the very existence of humankind.
Brazil's Amazon Rainforest
is being devastated by fires.
A battle between economic development
and environmental concerns.
With thousands of miners
invading the forests to hunt for gold.
Nearly 10,000 square kilometres
of the Amazon are destroyed in 2019.
Displacing hundreds of
indigenous communities
pushing them to the edge.
CNA investigates
why the lungs of the world are being lost.
Sao Paulo, Brazil.
By 3 pm,
the city is smothered
by black clouds of smoke.
Scientists eventually discover the cause.
Fires raging
in the far north of the country
thousands of miles away
in the Amazon Rainforest.
Official figures show
more than 87,000 Amazon fires
are recorded in Brazil
in the first eight months of 2019.
An increase of 76% from 2018.
These fires destroy 10,000 sq kilometres
of the Amazon in 2019.
While the Brazilian government
fails to act...
the world responds with outrage...
with criticism focused on newly elected
far-right President Jair Bolsonaro.
After Bolsonaro's election,
Brazil's environmental agencies
had their budgets slashed.
His economic policies
have focused on developing the economy
inside the Amazon Rainforest.
But Aldem's investigation
unearthed a bigger problem.
Lack of implementation
of Brazil's forest laws.
From 1980 to 2019,
penalties for cutting trees down
in protected areas totalled US$17 billion.
Less than 4%
of these fines were collected.
Corruption and the inability
to collect fines
have encouraged more violators
to set shop inside the Amazon.
With hundreds and thousands
of dollars to be made.
The cleared land is used to produce
beef and agri products,
a large portion of which
is exported to parts of Asia.
People need to understand that
we are all responsible for this.
So, even people far away in Pakistan,
in China, in Australia,
are also contributing to the
environmental problems in the Amazon,
because they are consumers.
They're helping to consume products
that are coming from this region.
Worldwide,
forests still cover about
30% of the planet.
But they are disappearing
at an alarming rate.
Between 1990 and 2016,
the world lost 1.3 million
square kilometres of forest,
according to the World Bank.
That's an area larger than South Africa.
We arrive in the state of Para
to investigate the effects
of the fires in northern Brazil.
The burnt down jungles
now resemble a war zone.
Erika Berenguer
is an environmental scientist,
who's lived in the Amazon
for the last 10 years,
studying the destructive force
of the fires here.
Erika takes us for a walk
inside a protected area
to show us the impact of fires
on the Amazon.
The Amazon Rainforest has
410 billion trees in this region alone,
with a total of 76 billion tons
of carbon stored in them.
Animals are being affected too.
It's believed that there are about
three million different species
of plant and animal life in the Amazon.
But President Bolsonaro wants to abolish
protection for indigenous lands.
His calls have been echoed by miners,
who've put self-preservation
ahead of environmental conservation.
After the break,
we meet these miners
who have invaded the Amazon
in search of gold.
Brazil is one the biggest
gold producers in the world.
With output reported
at 81 million kilograms in 2018.
But there is a new gold rush
in Brazil today,
one fuelled by soaring unemployment
in regions inside the Amazon Rainforest.
They're invading public lands,
logging the trees,
doing some gold mining
and damaging these areas,
or doing some fishing and hunting.
As the planet loses
the Amazon Rainforest at a rapid pace,
there are miners
on the other end of the equation
who are making increasing gains.
Locally known as garimpeiros,
their rising incomes developed cities
like Peixoto de Azevedo.
Located in Mato Grosso state,
they are gold producing hubs
for Brazil's lucrative gold industry.
Today, miners have become more organised,
creating cooperatives
to hunt for gold collectively.
One such cooperative is called Coogavepe
that was founded in 2008 by
former Sao Paulo banker Gilson Camboim.
He takes us for a tour
of the Coogavepe's gold mines
that are under his supervision.
Such gold mines are legal
as part of the Brazilian government's
strategy to monetise the Amazon.
But drone images reveal
the damage to the environment.
This was once a lush green forest
with flora and fauna
spread all across the landscape.
It's been replaced by
energy guzzling machines.
Coogavepe alone has deforested
3,000 square kilometres
of Amazon Rainforest since 2008.
Gold mining in the Amazon Rainforest
is attractive for the high yield of gold.
On average,
the concentration of gold
is 0.5 gram for every one ton of soil.
Inside the Amazon,
the yield is much higher.
Gold is found underground
after the topsoil is removed.
Once a 10-metre ditch is ready,
the miners at Coogavepe,
villagers from rural Brazil, get to work.
A hydraulic machine is parked near
the edge of this vast mining pit
that has been carved into
the rainforest's reddish-brown earth.
Hundreds of gallons of mud sludge
produced by the miners
is passed over carpets...
with the hope that
gold flakes stick to it.
The carpet is then washed into drums
and the mud is taken to the final process.
After extensive panning,
mercury is used to extract gold
from the mud
through a process
called amalgamation.
The crew at Coogavepe
work without protective equipment
or procedures to help them
discard the mercury safely.
The amalgam of mercury and gold
goes through the final process.
The heat applied evaporates the mercury,
and the gold is left in the pan.
Coogavepe mined 400 grams of gold today.
This is distributed equally
amongst everyone at the mine.
It will sell for US$500.
In the poor countryside,
that is a fortune
for a day of hard labour.
The raw gold is sold to shops in the city,
who process it into gold bars.
The final product is exported
to countries across Asia,
the Middle East and America.
Earning billions of dollars
in revenue for the government.
Mines like Coogavepe are legal.
And all part of President Bolsonaro's
master plan to monetise the Amazon.
But what about the Amazons?
On the ground,
the damage done by legal mines
is irreversible.
By law,
Coogavepe is supposed to restore
the forests once the mine is closed.
So Gilson takes us
to a restored part of the mine.
He's turned one area into a fish farm
while planting trees in another.
As greed takes over
concern for the environment,
many miners are going for the big bucks,
by starting their own mines.
Deep inside protected territories,
away from the authorities.
After the break,
we dig deep into illegal mining,
and meet the people
whose lands have been invaded
in the protected forests of Brazil.
Brazil's Amazon Rainforest
is one of the planet's
best defences against climate change.
It absorbs billions of tons
of carbon dioxide.
But deforestation for logging, mining
and for farming crops
and livestock has devastated it.
In the last 10 years,
the rainforest has lost an area
the size of 8.4 million soccer fields.
But the mining companies
want to use indigenous lands,
to expand operations,
and make more profits.
They are pushing
for a change in Brazilian law
allowing firms to mine
inside protected lands
and indigenous reserves
across the nation.
Despite having protected status,
indigenous territories
are already facing an invasion.
In Para state alone,
Brazilian authorities estimate
that 30 metric tons of illegal gold
worth about US$1.1 billion
has been excavated.
That's six times more than the legal
amount of gold traded in Brazil.
This mining boom could lead to the
extinction of indigenous communities
that have weathered centuries
of calamities in Brazil's rainforests.
Roughly 900,000 indigenous people
live in Brazil,
less than 0.5% of the population.
They belong to 400 tribes
and speak more than 270 languages.
On such tribe facing illegal mining
in their protected areas
are the Munduruku.
We travel 16 hours to the city of Bubure.
We are on the Tapajos River in Para state
and we're heading to the Munduruku lands,
indigenous protected lands
by the Brazilian government
that have been invaded
by illegal gold miners
and we're going to meet
the chief of the tribe
to understand the extent of the problem.
Juarez is the Chief
of the Munduruku Tribe.
He leads nearly 14,000 members,
who have splintered
into dozens of small villages,
scattered across a territory
slightly larger than 3,360 soccer fields.
They have lived here
for thousands of years.
That's why Juarez has to create borders
or more commonly known as demarcation
to identify his tribe's indigenous lands.
Motivated by the surging
international price of gold,
miners choose to prospect for gold
in protected reserves to evade taxes.
It's estimated that nearly
50,000 illegal miners
are working inside Para state alone.
Permanently evicting indigenous people
from their land is forbidden
under article 231
of Brazil's Constitution.
But the Bolsonaro government is planning
to build dams and infrastructure
in the Tapajos River basin
to boost the economy.
Armed with machetes,
Juarez and his crew ensure
the conservation of 178,000 hectares
of Amazon rainforest.
Juarez takes us to one
such illegal mining site,
an hour's boat ride on the Tapajos River.
As we arrive,
we spot a mining transport truck.
We tread carefully
as most of the miners are armed
and do not like visitors.
Miners in protected areas such as this
excavate land deep inside the forests,
away from the authorities
keeping clear of any inspections.
As we reach an abandoned mining pit,
the extent of the devastation
can only be gauged from high above.
Kilometres of protected Amazon Rainforest
are now mere ditches.
We don't venture too far,
we've been warned
that the illegal miners may open fire.
Five tribal leaders have already
lost their lives in this battle.
But with little enforcement of the law,
the destruction continues.
A map published by an NGO
shows illegal mining sites
in 37 indigenous territories.
In total,
nearly 2,300 illegal mining sites
with sophisticated infrastructure
have been found in protected areas.
Juarez fears for his life
and his community.
Currently, in Brazil,
mining on indigenous territories
is totally prohibited.
The Amazon contains about 20% of
the world's total volume of river water.
More than 80% of the world's food
has its origins in this rainforest.
Apart from tearing down native forests,
miners have also started
digging for gold in the rivers,
contaminating these waterways
with mercury.
Dredging for gold disrupts rivers,
toxic pollutants seep into plants,
animals and people.
Juarez and his community
can no longer fish in the river,
they have to hunt for food on land.
Researchers found 92% of all hair
and fish samples collected here
had high levels of mercury,
resulting in abnormalities
in the central nervous system of infants.
So, Juarez has decided
to take things into his own hands.
After the break,
we follow the Munduruku
as they plan to invade Brazil's Congress,
to pressure politicians to take action.
Brazil's President Jair Bolsonaro
plans to reduce indigenous territories
in the Amazon Rainforest.
The tribes are being sacrificed
to help boost the economy
to create jobs.
The mining sector is encroaching
into the rainforest
and the hunt for gold has begun.
In 2018,
Brazil's gold export increased 150%,
on an output of 95 tons.
With demand rising,
miners are pushing deeper
inside protected forests,
radically changing
the landscape forever.
This is why indigenous tribes have decided
to invade the federal capital, Brasilia.
Alessandra Korap,
a Munduruku indigenous activist
is leading the charge.
Alessandra has arrived in Brasilia,
the country's capital,
to meet her Munduruku clan.
A local school's been turned
into a makeshift camp.
These 50 Munduruku tribals plan to visit
Brazil's Congress to meet politicians.
And demand that their lands,
protected under Brazil law, be left alone.
According to Brazil's National Institute
for Space Research,
in 2018 alone,
five square kilometres of indigenous
Munduruku land was deforested.
In 2019,
the tree massacre increased
to 15 square kilometres.
Alessandra believes illegal miners
have the backing of politicians.
Next day, the tribe prepares for battle,
They believe Bolsonaro's rhetoric
has encouraged the advance of the miners
deeper into indigenous territory.
The Munduruku are on their way
to Congress to block a bill
that will allow mining companies to
operate inside indigenous lands legally.
It's a key campaign promise
of President Bolsonaro.
If approved, indigenous tribes and
their way of life may be gone forever.
An economic recession in Brazil
has driven large numbers of
unemployed villagers into the jungle
to hunt for gold.
The price is being paid
by indigenous people.
The Munduruku arrive at Brazil's Congress,
the main legislative body of the country.
This movement is helped by the country's
only indigenous congresswoman,
Joenia Wapichana.
She's only the second indigenous woman
to have ever been elected to Congress.
Of more than
594 congress representatives,
only three show up.
The others celebrate a football team's
participation in a local league.
In a separate chamber,
Alessandra makes an impassioned plea
for the right to the Munduruku.
As Brazil is polarised on the issue
of mining in the Amazon,
other industries
are coming up with solutions.
Laurent started Pecsa,
a cattle ranching firm in June 2015.
He helps Brazilian farmers
with sustainable cattle farming.
According to the Amazon Institute,
some 12 million hectares of cattle field
have been degraded in the Amazon region.
To create new grazing land,
vast expenses of the Amazon are cleared.
To date, an estimated 70%
of deforested Amazon
has been converted into pasture land.
But Pecsa offers a solution.
So, here we use rotated grazing.
Rotated grazing means that
we have a production model
that has several divisions.
And the cattle will stay in one division
for just a few days
and then go to the other one
and then to the other one.
And while the cattle do this cycle,
the first one is resting.
This allows...
First, the fact that the cattle
always has access
to the best part of the plant,
only the leaves.
Doing an efficient production,
we don't need to clear any more land.
Many big corporations over the world
have made commitments to remove
deforestation from the supply chains.
From 2010 to 2017,
Brazil's beef exports
climbed 25% to 1.5 million tons,
with Hong Kong importing the most.
To accommodate global beef demand,
cattle ranchers
are driving their herds deeper
into the Amazon Rainforest.
But since operations began
in Alta Floresta,
Pecsa has restored 10,000 hectares
of pasture land.
It now runs 20 farms that
sustainably manage cattle,
34,000 in 2017 alone.
For Laurent,
reinventing cattle feed
was another necessity of the hour.
Methane emitted by livestock
accounts for about 5.5%
of worldwide greenhouse gasses.
Greenhouse gasses will increase
global temperatures.
When they have this poor diet,
only based on pasture
and low-quality pasture
they produce more methane.
When we do the reform of the pastures,
and then we introduce this supplement,
we change the diet of the animals,
so we have two benefits.
One is to reduce by more or less 40%
the amount of methane
that is emitted by the animals.
So, when you consider
the methane of the animals
and also the carbon from the soil,
altogether, the emissions
are reduced by 90%.
Today, the deforestation
in the Amazon
claims an area of the size
of two football fields a minute.
If consumption patterns don't change,
50% of the Amazon may vanish by 2030,
destroying one of the world's
largest carbon sinks.
Protecting existing rainforests
and aggressively planting new ones,
may be the only way forward.
And perhaps one of the last few ways
to help save this planet,
and all who call it home.
Pakistan's Himalayan glaciers are melting
at the fastest rate in human history.
Nearly 36% of its ice sheet
will be gone by 2100.
In a battle for water in Kashmir,
a nuclear flashpoint
between India and Pakistan.
We want justice!
Impacting the water needs of
more than 2 billion people in South Asia.
With rising heatwaves in mega cities
increasing water consumption,
communities are fighting over
dwindling supplies.
So basically, we're inside
illegal theft area.
I don't think many Pakistanis
know how bad it is.
Could an ambitious tree-planting drive
save the melting glaciers?
So we want to restore
1,000,000 hectares in Pakistan.
Karachi...
Pakistan's largest city
with a population of 20 million.
The economic nerve centre of the country
is brought to a standstill.
A severe heat wave strikes
the southern port city in June 2015,
with temperatures
as high as 49 degrees Celsius.
The blazing sun causes total mayhem.
Unaware and unprepared,
more than 2,000 people across Karachi
perish from dehydration and heat stroke.
Hospitals are ill equipped
to deal with such a calamity.
The Abbasi Shaheed hospital mortuary
runs out of space.
As a result, mass graves are dug
to dispose off the bodies.
Memories of 2015 have come back
to haunt Karachi today.
In 2019, the heatwave has returned
with average daytime temperatures
hitting 49 degrees.
The Sindh government
declares a city-wide emergency.
We head out to the Abbasi Shaheed
Hospital's heat stroke unit.
To our surprise,
there are no heatstroke patients today.
Karachi government officials
are also better prepared.
Mobile units equipped with water sprays,
are deployed strategically
during the hotter hours of the day.
Despite the 49-degree temperature today,
no casualties are reported.
This is the new normal in Karachi.
An international climate report
puts Pakistan at number six
on the list of top 10 countries
most affected by climate change.
And in mega cities like Karachi,
lack of trees,
miles of asphalt roads and tall buildings
have increased heat absorption.
Making matters worse
is an unchecked growing population
in poorly planned
yet densely populated settlements.
Karachi is a spectacular example
of population explosion.
It was a small coastal city
which became the capital city
and it is now the largest city.
So in terms of population,
you have more people,
you need more water.
You have more shops and factories.
Also, mismanagement.
Karachi did not manage
to protect its water courses.
With rising temperatures,
the massive population of Karachi
consumes more water.
Karachi needs 1.1 billion gallons daily
to supply water
to roughly 20 million residents.
But the Water Board,
the city's water distributor,
is only able to provide
550 million gallons per day.
Mohammad Arif is a resident of Korangi.
His tap runs dry.
Broken water distribution lines
multiply the problem for Karachiites.
At 2am,
Arif arrives at the main distribution
pipeline of the government,
a hundred metres from his home.
He plans to divert water to his home
with the aid of hoses
and a hand-held motor.
There are nearly a million people
in this neighbourhood of Korangi alone.
And everyone's thirsty.
So what does the Water Board,
Karachi's water distributor have to say?
As water becomes rare
and difficult to access,
a black market is thriving.
According to the Karachi Water
and Sewerage Board,
42% of water is lost
in distribution before reaching consumers.
So where does all this water go?
We go in search of Karachi's water thieves
for an answer to this question.
After much deliberation,
we finally convince a water thief
to take us to his theft point.
We film the process secretly.
So basically, we are inside
the illegal theft area
where the water is stolen in Karachi.
The water thief takes us
to a congested slum.
In the meantime, the mastermind arrives
to explain how it works.
He takes us to where
he steals the water from.
Water that he then sells
at exorbitant rates,
while government officials get their cut.
Theft, corruption, and disrepair
hamper water access for millions
in Pakistan's largest city.
It costs millions of dollars in losses
to the national exchequer.
This stolen water is diverted from
the poor to the rich who can pay more.
A short-term solution the city developed
for its water needs
were water tankers
that now control
much of Karachi's water distribution.
More than 10,000 tankers operate
in the city under government control,
making an estimated 50,000 delivery trips
to consumers across Karachi each day.
But with few checks and balances,
excessive bribes kick in
when heatwaves hit Karachi,
allowing tanker drivers
to jack up rates as they will.
Delivery of a 1,000-gallon water tanker
now costs between $12 and $18 per trip.
This is a steep price,
especially for larger, poorer families
who spend a third of their income
on stolen water.
A global study projects
that nearly five billion people
will live in water-stressed
regions by 2050,
while the United Nations estimates
that water shortages
can displace hundreds of millions
of people as early as 2030.
Water is a massive political issue
in Karachi
and corruption is
in the middle of it all,
with one political party
depriving the water needs
of another party's constituency.
While solving Karachi's water crisis
seems like a distant pipe dream,
the residents of Karachi are left with
no option but to buy stolen water.
After the break,
we embed with the
Karachi Water Task Force
in their efforts to stop water theft.
Karachi.
Pakistan's largest city has an epidemic.
To capitalise on climate change
related water shortages,
Karachi's black market
for water is thriving.
Millions of dollars' worth of
government water is being stolen
and sold to people
who can pay a premium.
So the Karachi Water Board
has stepped up their efforts.
Chief Security Officer Tabish Raza
heads the task force against water theft.
As soon as we reach the location,
the thieves are spotted
and the raid begins.
A water motor is confiscated
in the raid
as Tabish explains the kind of money
changing hands
in Karachi's illegal water industry.
Tabish has received another tip-off
from a neighbouring town.
A textile factory is stealing
and reselling water.
The illegal pump from the bore
is taken out and confiscated.
This is a daily routine
for Tabish and his team.
They arrest the perpetrators
and destroy 10 pumps a day.
But in a city of 20 million people,
and with limited resources,
the Karachi Water Board
can only play catch-up with the thieves.
And climate change will only worsen
Karachi's water woes.
Climate change will mean more floods,
it will mean more droughts,
it will mean heatwaves like the one
we saw in Karachi 2 years ago,
it will mean reduction in the quantity
and reduction in the quality of water.
Both are serious.
There will be significant health impacts.
Soaring temperatures in South Asia
are reaching peak levels
due to rising greenhouse gas emissions.
The heat is melting the water wall
of South Asia
the Himalayas, that supply water
to the rest of the subcontinent.
The glaciers in northern Pakistan
in the disputed region of Kashmir
are the biggest ice sheets
outside the polar regions.
These ice sheets are melting.
We drive 15 hours
from Islamabad to Gulmit,
a village in northern Pakistan
to investigate its impact.
According to a new study,
36% of the glaciers found in the region
will be gone by 2100.
Sitara Parveen is a glaciologist who has
studied these ice sheets for a decade.
This was once an area which had
plenty of water from this glacier
because the glacier was much higher,
and even up to the levels
of these moraines.
You can see here.
This moraine shows
the level was much higher.
So, the water was recharging
these irrigation channels.
The glaciers are very sensitive
to climate.
They react according to
the temperature and precipitation.
When it is hot, it melts a lot.
Since 1988,
the snow line in northern Pakistan
has receded by 1.1 kilometres.
What scientists and glaciologists
thought wasn't possible in 1,000 years
has happened within 30.
If global emissions stay
at current levels,
future generations
may never see ice in South Asia.
These glaciers are also important
for these farmers who are living here,
who depend on agriculture
for their livelihood.
Because you can see that
this is a very moisture-deficit area,
less rainfall in these plain areas
where the people practice agriculture.
So, it is not possible without
the water from these glaciers.
Nestled in the Karakoram mountains
as high as 23,000 feet,
village communities like these
are vulnerable.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
We welcome you today...
Lakes forming within the glaciers
often burst
causing flash floods,
destroying life and property downstream.
Shaukat Ali,
a local resident and tour guide
takes us to the Ghulkin Glacier.
Due to pollution,
fine particles of "black carbon"
are deposited onto white glaciers...
speeding up the melting process.
After a three-hour trek over ice,
we arrive at the Ghulkin Glacier,
one of the largest in northern Pakistan.
Streams of water run down
into the crevasses
collecting at the bottom of the glacier.
As the sun blazes onto the ice sheet,
Shaukat points out,
this water collects into a massive lake
within the glacier
that can burst anytime
and flood the village downstream.
In June 2019,
a glacial lake formed
in the neighbouring Shisper Glacier
that forced the government to react.
Local officials hurriedly built
a concrete wall
to prevent the water
from bursting the banks.
But they stood no chance
in front of the savage wall of water
that came hurtling down at the village.
Tariq remembers that fateful day.
Tariq believes more than 30 homes
were washed away,
and if proper planning was done,
they could have been saved.
Tariq takes us to the Shisper Glacier.
He believes
it's the next disaster in the making.
This black glacier is physically
moving 5-6 metres a day
downstream to the village
due to rising temperatures.
And local communities are concerned
if it's going to destroy homes again.
The region is expected to face
mass water shortages in around 50 years
when glaciers become too small.
After the break,
we take you to the highest
militarised zone in the world,
where India and Pakistan
are battling a war on top of a glacier.
Pakistan has been bestowed with five
of the biggest rivers in the world.
The mighty Indus, Jhelum, Chenab,
Ravi and Sutlej that have cascaded down
the plains of the Punjab
for hundreds of years.
These rivers are formed by
melting glaciers in the Karakoram
and Himalayan ranges.
One such glacier is nestled between
India and Pakistan,
in the eastern Karakoram range
in the Himalayas.
It's called the Siachen Glacier
and is claimed, in full,
by both Pakistan and India.
It's been disputed territory
after the two countries split in 1947.
The contended area is a sheet of ice
nearly 1,000 square miles in total.
Unable to settle the land dispute
diplomatically,
troops were amassed on top
of the glacier by both countries.
Pakistan and India
have spent millions of dollars a month
to keep troops posted here.
At 6,700 metres, it is the highest
militarised zone in the world.
The dispute over land between India
and Pakistan transcends downstream,
to the waters that continue to flow
from India to Pakistan.
After partition in 1947,
India and Pakistan
were unsure of how to share water.
Hence, the Indus Waters Treaty
was signed in 1960
between then Indian Prime Minister
Jawaharlal Nehru
and Pakistani President Ayub Khan
in Karachi.
Brokered by the World Bank,
the treaty allowed both countries
to use the water available
in the Indus System of Rivers.
The two countries, due to
historical problems and animosity,
could not agree on joint management,
so it was considered a second partition
should take place.
Pakistan got the rights to use
the three western rivers,
the Indus, Jhelum
and Chenab exclusively,
while India won the rights
to use the three eastern rivers,
the Ravi, Sutlej and Beas.
But today, tensions between
the nuclear neighbours over Kashmir
is putting pressure on this water treaty.
The Hindu nationalist BJP led by
Prime Minister Modi has rattled things.
Modi now wants to build dams
to block the flow of water into Pakistan,
making the Indus river, a hotspot
that might escalate into a nuclear war.
I think the next fight
would be over the water.
The world is going to fight over water.
And we never realised.
And this Indus Waters Treaty,
when it was done in 1970s
that was the time that
we could have solved the problem.
But India is always more authoritative,
they never obey the rules
even if they are international
so this treaty remained,
what would I say...
It remained just in the books.
Pakistan's semi-arid climate
means more than 90% of harvests
depend on irrigation.
You are going to have Pakistanis
receiving less water
so when you receive less water,
you blame the supplier.
There is a potential...
source of conflict.
And the Secretary-General made a report
to the UN Secretary-General.
Made a specific reference
to India and Pakistan
and said that climate change
is likely to put pressure
on the Indus Waters Treaty
which has served the two countries
for almost 60 years.
Despite four full-blown wars,
India and Pakistan
have never had a water war
but the situation in the disputed region
of Kashmir is escalating.
A majority of Pakistan's rivers originate
from Indian-administered Kashmir.
And in August 2019,
India did the unthinkable.
India's dams released nearly
6 million litres of water per second
into Pakistan without intimation.
The Pakistani province of Punjab
was flooded,
drowning hundreds of acres
of agricultural land.
Islamabad reacted angrily.
It claimed this unexpected release
of water into the River Sutlej
that flows from India to Pakistan
was part of an attempt by New Delhi
to flout the Indus Waters Treaty.
This was followed by the revocation
of Article 370 in 2019,
to eliminate the special status
of Indian-administered Kashmir,
an area claimed by Pakistan.
As geopolitical realities
mix with a potential water war,
the reaction in
Pakistan-administered Kashmir is intense.
Go back!
We want freedom!
Go India!
Go back!
We travel to Pakistan-controlled Kashmir
at the frontline of this complex battle
where tempers are reaching boiling point.
Such rallies in
Pakistan-administered Kashmir
have become routine.
Frequent protests are putting pressure
on the Pakistani Army
to liberate Indian-administered Kashmir.
And secure the supply of water
for mainland Pakistan as well.
The government of
Pakistan-administered Kashmir
fears that Prime Minister Modi
may usurp the Indus Waters Treaty
and leave Pakistan
in a drought-like situation.
In a never-ending conflict
between two nuclear armed countries,
more than 50,000 Kashmiris
have lost their lives.
Will the water dispute claim more?
After the break,
we look at Prime Minister
Imran Khan's Billion Tree Tsunami,
that's being billed as the idea
that could save the region.
December, 2019.
New Delhi is in the grips
of an intense smog.
The air quality index
reads as high as 1,000.
The smog transcends the border
over to parts of Pakistan.
A blame game erupts between
politicians on either side of the border.
NASA satellite data shows
a heavy concentration of fires
on the Indian side
and far fewer
on the Pakistani side of the border.
The end result was a deadly smog
and downgrading of air quality
across the subcontinent,
particularly in India.
Cricket star-turned-Prime Minister
Imran Khan's surprising response
grabbed headlines.
His party, the Pakistan Tehreek-e-Insaf
spearheaded Billion Tree Tsunami in 2014
at a cost $169 million.
This was the Pakistani government's
response to the challenge
of global warming in South Asia.
Pakistan has the lowest tree cover
in the region,
giving it more reason to reforest.
A billion trees were planted
from 2014 to 2018.
But Prime Minister Khan
isn't stopping here.
He has vowed to plant 10 billion trees
in the next 5 years of his government.
10 Billion Tree Tsunami,
but before that,
it was actually Billion Tree Tsunami.
It was started by
Prime Minister Imran Khan.
At that time,
he was not the prime minister.
And we had one province government
that was called KPK.
This was the first green initiative
that our country started in 73 years.
It was one of the different
and finest projects
that any government
on the provincial level started.
It was known as
Billion Tree Tsunami,
and it has made a mark
in history and the world.
The plan is to increase
the forest cover in the country
and attract rains
that will reduce rising temperatures.
In total,
Pakistan has restored 350,000 hectares
of forests and degraded land
to surpass its
Bonn Challenge commitment.
Pakistan's Vision 2025
is aiming to work on better
water management as well.
Due to traditional farming techniques,
two-thirds of irrigation water is lost
through system leakages
across the country.
That's why farmers like Ashiq Bangash
have stepped in.
A resident of Islamabad,
Bangash decided to introduce
drip irrigation
into Pakistan's traditional
farming system.
Pakistan is among the six countries that
will be most affected by global warming.
And a rising population calls for
measures to protect natural resources.
2025 has been marked
as the year when Pakistan
may turn into a "water-scarce" country,
unable to meet its water needs.
Existing reservoirs' storage capacity
cannot sustain
Pakistan's population boom
while river flow has also
been reduced over the years.
Pakistan can get more economic,
social and environmental benefits
from better water use.
But it's subject to continuous reforms
to improve water use efficiency
and service delivery,
and create awareness
among the general public.
In Lahore,
Pakistanis are rising to the challenge
to put pressure on politicians
across Pakistan to do more.
People don't understand how bad it is.
Just this year there were floods,
unexpected rains in Punjab
that wiped out a substantial portion
of the wheat crop,
that affected people's livelihoods.
And for a country where a quarter of the
population is at or near the poverty line,
a single event like that, one rain,
is the difference between
getting a square meal a day or not.
In a country beset with problems,
only 4% think that climate change
is an issue.
Rafay wants to change this attitude.
He's taking his family
to the Climate March
to raise awareness
amongst kids in Pakistan.
Will you be leading the march?
No, we're going to help organise it.
The children are leading the march,
the students, not us.
It's safer.
Paper and pen.
All right, so we've got a march
in Mianwali currently underway.
The youth of Pakistan
are concerned about their future
when the impact of climate change
may worsen.
More than 5,000 marches
take place worldwide
along with Lahore on the same day.
The Climate Strike is the largest ever
collective call to action in the world.
My government is the
biggest polluter in history
and should be doing something about it
but instead President Trump
doesn't even believe in climate change
and wants to pull us out
of the Paris Agreement.
I find it completely unacceptable,
especially because my friends
and in-laws here in Pakistan
are the ones who
are already suffering the most
from the impact of climate change.
We want justice!
Pakistan contributes less than 1%
of the world's greenhouse gases.
Yet, it is the world's
sixth most vulnerable country
affected by climate change.
While it must develop
a robust foreign policy
that allows it to effectively negotiate
climate issues with its neighbours,
Pakistan's march to solve
its climate problems has begun.